I shift for more on the crisis at the
southern border joining us now live to
weigh in Arizona attorney general Mark
bernovich Mr attorney general thank you
for taking time as you saw in Alexis's
report obviously it is not getting
better it's getting worse it's
unprecedented 2 million plus we've been
reporting the migrant deaths even though
they won't publish it at 787 this fiscal
year never seen those kind of numbers 35
alone in September you can see the
number there but let me play for you it
is at the point now that other channels
are beginning to take notice to report
on it and ask officials who by the way
refuse our opportunities to come on here
but secretary mayorkis was asked about
this crisis on another channel here was
the exchange I want to get your reaction
watch
secretary I'm here in El Paso we're
about 2 000 people are arriving every
day this fiscal year we're looking at
roughly 2.4 million apprehensions
countless others are crossing and not
being apprehended secretary what is the
United States border policy
well we are doing so much uh Jose you
know what our policy is our policy is to
enforce the law and that is indeed what
we are doing Mr attorney general are
they enforcing the law
um I I actually think that answers
comical but this is no joke the American
people are paying the price for this
absolutely not you just went through
Griff the record amount of number of
people coming into this country but I
think we need to focus on a couple of
other things just in August just in the
month of August more people had
encounters with border patrol that were
coming in the country illegally then the
entire population of Little Rock
Arkansas we know that since Biden's
taking over as president the enough to
fill three U.S states have crossed our
border illegally but we also know people
on the terror watch list have come into
this country in record amounts we know
that fentanyl is pouring into our
country in record amounts and Americans
are dying and in fact as a prosecutor
when I see the price of fentanyl fall
from twenty dollars a pill to five
dollars a pill I know that our sons
daughters nieces nephews our children
are going to be dying and that's why you
see these staggering numbers where
most people now that age group of 18 to
49 are dying as a result of those
overdoses so so Americans are dying
people are coming in record numbers
criminals are coming in America is less
safe so but I do not know what measure
secretary mayorkas is is using so I
think um their lack of Integrity is only
surpassed by his ineptitude are
arizonans uh paying attention to this is
this going to be an issue for the
midterm elections there in your state
yeah I think people are definitely
concerned about it you know I've said
this for for the last year this election
is and should be about security border
security and economic security people
want to feel safe you know they want to
be able to you know send their kids to a
good school and not know that there's
it's going to be inundated with drugs or
when their kids are walking to school
they're not going to be gunned down as a
result of gang violence as the cartels
uh perpetuate more and more violence
into our community so it should matter
um but you know at the end of the day I
also think that people are worried about
their economy because in Joe Biden's
America you know gas prices are rising
record numbers grocery prices are rising
and it seems like the only thing that
Joe Biden thinks is wrong with our
border is that he can't let more illegal
people into our country we will see how
arizonans react to the Border issue I
want to take a moment though and shift
gears Mr attorney general with you if I
can just to the news coming late
yesterday a ruling with with regards to
abortion undoing decades old law that
would ban outright abortions and it
comes on the same day today when the
15-week law was to set uh to take to
take effect and so if you could sir just
clarify for all arizonans exactly what
the law is today as we speak and where
things stand
you know we were involved in litigation
trying to clarify the law and yesterday
a judge in Pima County said that ARS
13-3603 which was re-codified in 1977
which was based on a previous law a
pre-roll law law law that basically said
all abortions are illegal in Arizona
except in the case to save the mother
now me personally I've said before that
I think there should be exceptions for
rape and incest but that's what the law
is and just this year our legislature
when they re-codified or they passed the
ban a 15-week ban they literally sat in
there that
13-3603 is not repealed it is still the
law on Arizona so you have this law from
1977. you have a law that was passed
this year that both say that there is a
complete ban and that's what the judge
said is indeed the valid law in Arizona
so so so so the the total ban except for
when it threatens the the pregnant
mother's life is in effect today in for
the foreseeable future for all women in
Arizona what is your reaction to women
who are saying that they now will have
to travel to other states and that they
feel that their rights have been set
back uh for decades
the job of the Attorney General is to
enforce the law as it is and I've said
this many a Time on various issues
including this this issue of abortion
which is in many ways so emotional and
controversial for people you know you
have Republicans out there saying that
they want to protect life and protect
the most vulnerable you know and
Democrats are talking about you know
women's right to choose But ultimately
you have a republican legislature and
you have a republican Governor that
signed a bill that says this is the law
in Arizona so if people don't like the
law they should take it up with their
legislators or they should take it up
with their elected officials in Congress
or their governor
attorney general mark brnovich thank you
for coming on and talking about a number
of issues they're affecting arizonans
have a great Saturday sir thank you I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis